so tell me what Drew you to this role in
Hellraiser well
um I'm very familiar with the franchise
when I was a teenager I saw all first
four movies
um a Sci-Fi fan and I was I was looking
through my video store in the vicinity
of my house to some new science fiction
movie to see you know it was a lot of
stuff coming out of VHS at the time and
this was this Hellraiser four I never
heard of it and uh I took it because it
was a science fiction you know it's
happening up in a space station and
there's pieces of happening in in
Century and stuff like that so I'm I'm
watching the movie and I realized this
is like number four of something this is
not the original movie and then I get
back and I ask the guy do you have one
two and three of this this is pretty
cool [ __ ] you know part of my language
and the guy yeah you know these are
awesome you know these are amazing you
should see this one and this one you
know and then my buddy and I we saw
three of them in like two days or
something it was a summer some period so
when when this came across my desk you
know my manager was like you know do you
know about hellraising you know being
from Croatia and stuff I'm like dude do
I know about it I know about it of
course and then I read the script the
character was insane in the real sense
of the word and then I read the final
scene what's happening with him and I
was like oh my God this is like this is
this is a this can be really cool and
then I heard David Bruckner is directing
and I was like I familiar with David's
work and I love how he does things and
it was it was pretty much a no-brainer
you know but did you did it change your
thoughts on the Hellraiser franchise
after you saw the first three yeah I
mean it was completely different I mean
number four number four was you know
they were it was a Space Opera time you
know it was these big movies of Star
Wars it was raging it was Empire Strikes
Back Return of the Jedi time you know so
everybody was trying to cash in on Space
a little bit you know so Hellraiser was
doing the same thing but when I saw
number one I mean it's a completely
different Beast than number four yeah
and number two also so what we did in
our health razor it's kind of a little
bit of an homage to number one
you know there is no in today's day and
age you see a remake you know when I
hear the word the remake or you know I I
I have a idea of like tons of CGI and
computer animation and everything looks
kind of like Grand and fake so this one
we did like 90 of our tricks were
actually visual proper visual effects
and practical stuff that we did on set
it was not much computer generated
images so it was very easy for us to
kind of be drawn into that world you
know because all these Cena bites all
these this is all prosthetic this is all
real these are contact lenses costumes
and proper real chains and sets and
everything you know so it's it's really
pleasure for an actor lately to come on
set and have actually person to play
with not the CGI character or something
like that so it kind of reminds me that
he has that Spirit of that number one
the first one Hellraiser can you talk a
little bit about what it was like
playing with the lament configuration
box it was fascinating to see
knowing the knowing the history my
character starts in the beginning as
this kind of a powerful guy who looks at
everybody from Heights and he sees that
kid doing it for him and then all hell
breaks loose and now you see him second
time trying to do the same thing but
from completely different perspective
From perspective of a Broken Man of
somebody who's been in pain like
abnormal amount of pain for 24 7. and he
and he's still trying to achieve the
same thing you know and with these
configuration melting and molding into
something else it was really fascinating
to see we had all of them practical you
could you could hold them in your hands
and when they would use the uh different
elements you could actually crank them
and do that with them so it was really
you know your mind starts telling you
what if what if this is the real one you
know I saw the guy
we're gonna set camera is there David is
there you know you see the lights and
you know but still your brain is kind of
like
I'm not sure about this you know do you
consider
um Voit to be
a worse guy than the cenobites like a
bigger Baddie than the center bites well
I mean we still don't have a exact
answer what the Santa bites are David
and I discussed this but this was very
personal between us just to talk about
void and what he's trying to achieve and
who are these creatures this is not
official position of anybody this is
just two guys kind of have over coffee
brainstorming the characters and stuff
and we've been discussing about them
being literally explorers from different
dimension who are coming into our world
to experience things that they cannot
experience
in their Dimension you know they're
completely
they're completely differently perceive
our world and maybe maybe they're not
even that bad maybe they don't even know
how much effect on us they have it's
beautiful when priest talks to void and
she says to him I I misunderstood what
you want to achieve you didn't want that
oh my God I mean she almost apologizes
like I thought this is exactly what you
want now we never clarify this she's
serious in that moment or she's being
sarcastic and Jamie played it so
beautifully completely flat with her
beautiful voice just saying those words
and in a moment I'm thinking as as voids
was this really a gift you know so it's
all kind of like you you know I think
void is bigger bad guy just because he
really does that consciously these
creatures we still don't know who they
are and why I mean they they might as
well be aliens from different dimensions
you know from some planet that bunch of
people like them live there you know
well thank you so much um I really
appreciate it they're telling me my
thumbs up but um it was great seeing you
and um thank you so much thank you very
much thank you